you learn as you're going and get older
you make your own shortcut
always make it back home
you ready Glenn oh yeah
Glenn and I are off to put our Crab Pot
from Volga Bay where he has one and I
have one and that increases our chances
of getting crab
when we pull the crap out it's a long
way about 35-40 minutes skip ride
out here in the Open Water the weather
is not always in our favor because of
the swell that washes right up
the crab pots and we're gonna pull are
in a bay and it's a lot calmer and a lot
easier to get
we got to get everything before the
winter hits otherwise it's pretty hard
to get up there
you get some Wicked wins with Tide
flowing in and out
driving around out here is like studying
for a test
you gotta memorize where all the rocks
are
and it reads it's
where is my buoy
[Music]
your orange boy should be really easy to
see it it should be right here
you should see the buoy no matter how
many white caps are it's a big orange
buoyage just like my uncle Marvin's gear
he has on
[Music]
mine should be real close around here
this is that small Cork and it's very
hard to see
if we find Glenn's I got a good bearing
before my Crab Pot is I don't see mine
anywhere
core corrector Glenn
is that a cork I think that's your cork
well we use two parts yeah
[Music]
by not finding Glenn's that part
decreases the Chance by half because not
all the poles we do are success for king
crab
thank you
like that pipe out already up here I got
you
[Music]
there
our chances now are cut in half by
one pot missing and
hope we get something in this
[Music]
that would go
stop it
how do we do oh look at that
scored heavy
and we scored we are not going home
empty-handed
[Music]
there you go
a lot of females
I think we got a couple Keepers but
there's so much females I'm very happy
to see that take it over yeah I was so
happy to see females because I know that
at least there's from there to still
reproduce and that's a very good sign
it's a female green she had a female
brown belly big belly oh is that the
eggs right there you see them in there
oh yeah yeah there's a lot of eggs
females
it's the future there's anything that we
want is crab for the future here's a
male we'll keep how big it is
keeper here yeah you got your tree band
I'll take three okay all right
lost my pot but I'm bringing food home
good job
for worth the trip even with after Crab
Pot
found one Crab Pot
what's missing is my big orange buoy
[Music]